hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well when we're
considering the stoic attitude towards
emotions towards emotional life towards
activity in general the tendency is to
assume that stomachs were completely
against emotions and that's not entirely
the case at least not for most of them
going a little bit further what we see
happening in epictetus is on discussions
of this is that there is one particular
kind of effect that he focuses on it's
called Philip storm yeah in the Greek
but we translated it something like
familial affections well think about the
affection that parents have for their
children when things are actually the
way they want to be granted now every
parent is like that as epictetus is very
clear about in other parts but you don't
see this as something natural he's not
the only stoic who talks about this as
well he has a whole chapter on it in
book 1 chapter 11 is devoted to Phil
Astoria he also has a very important set
of remarks when he is criticizing the
Epicureans in book 1 in chapter 23 so
what should we make of this the context
of this is that a man comes to epictetus
and epictetus says oh you're a married
guy what's that like is it a this is
pretty good and guys that's terrible my
just for an example
my daughter is sick and I just couldn't
feels so much affection before I
couldn't bear to be in the room so I
left and epic you says well that's a
little strange
are you sure that what you're talking
about was the right thing and the dad
says well it was the natural thing lots
of dance do that sort of thing and then
I practices okay so we need to think
about this the father is saying that he
is motivated by this emotion on film
store dinner this this attachment
familial affection that that essentially
drives him away from his child in her
time of trouble in her time of need and
Epictetus is going to say look you you
are not actually acting on that basis at
all let's see what he has to say about
that so from a story perspective the
question then is is this effect
legitimate is this the sort of thing
that we want to be feeling or if it's
not the sort of thing that we ought to
be feeling and we are feeling it should
we ignore it should we try to suppress
it and Epix you says no we want to be
feeling it rightly we want to be feeling
genuine Phil Astoria not passing off
other things as that so here's the way
to frame this question as far as
Epictetus is concerned is feeling and
acting on this emotional state is it the
right thing to do and is that the
natural thing to do and the way that
Epictetus explains the natural I'm going
to talk about this much more in another
core concept video simply saying look a
whole bunch of other people tend to feel
that way and act
way doesn't mean that it's actually
natural to human beings to feel and act
that way as Epictetus says going astray
is not really natural that's not having
your pro erases your Faculty of choice
in accordance with nature as a matter of
fact there's a certain being out of
whack being out of sync involved in that
it may feel natural and may be taken as
natural but it's not really natural and
in that that discussion about the
epicurean saying here's what's wrong
with epicurean philosophy in book 1
chapter 23 he does say that at fiddle
scordia
is natural in one sense that now you
know it's not completely clear that he
really is asserting that this is the
case in every case was obviously if it
was he wouldn't be talking about bad
parents but he does say this here we go
once a child is born it's no longer in
our power not to love it or to care for
it and the words that that are being
translated as love it Phil Oh snoring
game is is the verb and to care for it
is to sort of to think carefully to take
care for it
throw nades in and so there is a natural
response that we have towards children
and perhaps even much about much broader
towards those that we encounter as
vulnerable and attached to us in some
way perhaps this feeling of the astoria
could be extended
you know quite quite wide in it within a
family a group of people living together
and epictetus is saying that it is
natural in that sense it also is natural
in another sense which aligns it much
closer to being right to being orthos to
be incorrect and with this he talks
about it in terms of it being reasonable
and and right another way to think about
this is
fits the role that the person has if you
are a parent you part of your role is to
take care of and to feel affection
towards your children you know and in
return children want to feel a similar
type of affection towards their parents
siblings ought to feel affection towards
each other
husband and wife ought to feel that sort
of thing in ancient times this is you
know saying that there's that there's a
something going on within the household
within the family that makes this this
not only legitimate but what is to be
desired from a stoic perspective so
there is a nice long discussion in there
that I'm not going to go into in full
but he says you know he reads this this
man who he's trying to set out on the
right path he says this famiglia family
affection seemed to you to you to be in
accordance with nature and good and the
guy says yeah okay well what that is it
possible well family affection is in
accordance with nature and good that
which is reasonable is not good says no
that's not the case
so that which is reasonable is not
incompatible with family affection who's
getting him halfway there no it is not I
think otherwise when two things are
incompatible and one of them is in
accordance with nature the other must be
contrary to nature must it not so II
think so yes
well whatever therefore we find it be at
the same time both affectionate and
reasonable this we confidently assert to
be both right and good
so familial affection when it's being
you know done in the proper way not like
crazy I'm going to just you know throw
myself down a well because I you know
worried so much about what you think of
me or that's not really familial
affection throwing me a giant sweet
sixteen party for spoiled kids that's
not familial affection the way epic use
is talking about it the middle of a
fashion is something
easier to feel and to to act upon but it
is reasonable and it is right now many
it sparks to the man this is gets us to
the last and most important point about
this what is not familial affection
leaving your sick child because you feel
some sort of negative effect to go off
and be like the other dads who can't be
in the room while the child is sick
that is not familial affection that is
something quite different and Epictetus
you know invites the man to think about
that there's a lot of cases I think if
we're going to broaden this much more
widely and think about it in our own
time where people are claiming that
something is done from a sense of
affection a sense of care for the other
but it's not really what's going on it's
more self-centered it's more about
guarding their ego or about you know not
dealing with certain emotions that
they're feeling and epictetus says
you're more like the person who is
worried about his gambling losses then
that's somebody who really cares for his
child the last thing that he says to the
guy to really drive this home is how
would you feel if the situation were
reversed and this gets us to why
familial affection we can recognize it
as something that is what we want to be
feeling because we think that other
people want to feel that towards us and
we get upset when they don't this is
what you know you were sick
would you want everybody to go away and
leave you alone and not take care of you
and not attend to you or would you pray
that they actually care about you so
much that they want to be by your
bedside when the man realizes okay I
have not been feeling familial affection
and then this is this part of them to
put one on the road towards properly
feeling this towards realigning the
effects and the judgments about things
so final word on this Epictetus things
that
laughs action when it is truly familial
affection it is in accordance with
nature it is the way that we want to be
it is part of having our Faculty of
choice in accordance with nature as well